la séance est ouverte
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les députés chers
collègues
j'ai l'honneur d'accueillir
nous avons l'honneur d'accueillir
aujourd'hui dans notre émission monsieur
rousselland Stéphane chouk président de
la Rada ukrainienne
il y a quelques mois une délégation de
l'Assemblée nationale s'est rendue à
Kiev
j'ai été à sa tête et nous sommes allés
dire la pluie indéfectible des députés
français à l'Ukraine et à son peuple
le président Stéphane chouk nous a
accueilli chaleureusement
avec lui nous sommes allés au contact
des Ukrainiens nous avons vu leur
extraordinaire résistance leur
détermination à se battre contre
l'agresseur russe et leur premier
efforts pour reconstruire le pays
à cette occasion monsieur le Président
de la radar vous nous avez demandé
d'être votre porte-voix auprès de
l'opinion publique française et
internationale et c'est ce que nous
avons fait
le 30 novembre dernier en effet
l'Assemblée nationale à l'issue d'un
débat nourri a voté une résolution
affirmant le soutien de l'Assemblée
nationale à l'Ukraine et condamnant la
guerre menée par la Fédération de Russie
depuis plusieurs députés se sont rendus
à Kiev pour marquer leur soutien
aujourd'hui pour la venue de Monsieur
Stéphane shock l'Assemblée nationale
Arbor les couleurs
ukrainiennes avec l'exposition des
œuvres de Christian guemi que nous
venons d'inaugurer ensemble puis
plusieurs réunions associant nos
commissions permanentes et le groupe
d'amitié France - Ukraine nouvellement
constituée
l'agression russe se poursuit effroyable
avec son lot d'exaction et de crimes de
guerre de bombardements aveugles et de
destruction chaque jour apporte de
nouvelles accablantes mais aussi chaque
jour les démocraties s'unissent pour
apporter tout le soutien nécessaire à
l'Ukraine
[Applaudissements]
pour la soutenir dans ce combat la
représentation nationale est pleinement
mobilisée aux côtés du gouvernement
français car le combat de l'Ukraine est
plus largement celui de nos valeurs
démocratiques celui de l'humanisme de la
liberté aussi nos deux assemblées
viennent-elles de signer un protocole
d'accord particulièrement
utile pour préparer l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne en effet
l'Ukraine fait partie de la famille
européenne et son destin se trouve dans
l'Union monsieur Stéphane Chouque
président quand vous reviendrez à Kiev
vous pourrez témoigner de l'entière
mobilisation de la représentation
nationale française en faveur du peuple
ukrainien et de sa souveraineté
[Applaudissements]
et c'est avec beaucoup d'émotions
beaucoup de plaisir et beaucoup d'amitié
que je vous aide à présent la parole et
que je vous invite à monter à la tribune
de l'Assemblée
[Applaudissements]
Shanna
[Musique]
tout d'abord
pour cette possibilité
de prendre la parole des vents les
députés de l'Assemblée nationale
française au coeur même de la vie
politique de votre pays
partenaires puissent entendre les
Ukrainiens
comme vous l'avez fait madame pendant
votre visite à Ukraine
je me souviens jusqu'au moindre détail
de votre visite à cueillent ensuite nous
sommes rendus ensemble en train dans la
ville voisine de turning c'était un acte
de courage
je n'oublierai jamais madame la
Présidente
comment vous avez tenu les mains
âgée qui a survécu après frappe de
missile sur sa maison vous avez pu voir
de vos propres yeux l'ampleur de
destruction de notre pays
vous avez ressenti la douleur et le
malheur de chaque ukrainien votre visite
est devenue un témoignage éclatant de
solidarité de la République française
avec le crâne la manifestation de
soutien de notre indépendance et de
notre intégrité territoriale
des principes qui nous réunissent
ce qui nous réunit aussi sont les ponts
fraternelle a transmis à la région de
tchernie
renforcer les ponts d'amitié et d'aide
magnétère entre les deux pays et on
était renforcés par les ponts de soutien
militaire et technique
les équipes accordées à l'Ukraine
l'aide militaire et les équipements et
nous construirons absolument de nouveau
pont qui vont réunir encore davantage
nos deux pays cela fait presque non que
l'agression en grande échelle de la
Russie contre
l'ukrainement parfaitement que son
unique
intention était
l'aspiration criminelle de la Russie de
s'emparer des territoires
étrangères privés l'Ukraine de
souveraineté empêché notre avenir
européen et eurotique la Russie utilise
contre nous l'ensemble des asseaux
disposent elle fait chanter le monde
donc d'utiliser les armes
destruction massive aujourd'hui
une possibilité exceptionnelle de tenir
dans mes mains les trésors de votre
bibliothèque un grand atlas
sur les cartes duquel est représentée
personnel de torride c'est ce même
personne qui récemment a été libéré par
l'armée ukrainienne
de plus j'ai eu l'occasion de voir un
livre exceptionnel et qui était en 1660
grands ingénieur cartographes voyageurs
et écrivain français Guillaume Le
Vasseur de beau plan description du
crânien il y a dans ce texte des paroles
sur le peuple
noble qui porte le nom des Cosaques
zapporoques
c'est un peuple subtil
de devenir riche mais grandement leur
liberté sans laquelle il ne voudrait
vivre
360 ans se sont
écoulés depuis cet instant l'Ukraine
résiste le crâne se bat car aujourd'hui
aussi elle n'imagine pas sa vie sans la
liberté
entre résistance l'agresseur répond par
les attaques contre nos villes nos
villages les sites d'infrastructures qui
privent les gens de chauffage
d'électricité d'eau
seulement aujourd'hui
depuis ce matin les
Ukrainiens sont descendus à trois
reprises dans les abris pour sauver leur
vie des missiles russes
l'agresseur
aspire à priver les Ukrainiens des
conditions dignes d'existence la
propagande sinueuse continue à produire
des mensonges des fake en utilisant une
erreur aussi bien ses propres
concitoyens coûte tous ceux qui le
encore dans le monde mais de fait ils
sont
donc participe à ce crime qui doit être
puni et tous les responsables doivent
être traduits devant le justice ce sont
les terroristes qui
font cela et c'est ainsi qu'agi en
régime terroriste et un état terroriste
il s'agit d'une politique agressive
irresponsable qui porte la menace pour
la liberté la démocratie la communauté
internationale doit y apporter une
appréciation adéquate ainsi le 23
novembre l'année dernière le Parlement
européen a reconnu la Russie comme est
un promoteur de terrorisme qui utilise
les méthodes terroristes les décisions
identiques avaient été prises par les
assemblées parlementaires de l'OTAN et
du Conseil de l'Europe par conséquent à
cette haute tribune je vous appelle
chers collègues à reconnaître la Russie
en tant qu'État terroristes dans les
murs de votre temple de droits et de
liberté dans ces murs
[Applaudissements]
importantes et le 30 novembre de l'année
dernière la résolution de soutenir le
crâne adopté dans ses murs qui a
condamné l'agression russe en fait
partie ce qui est important c'est que
cette résolution
soutient l'idée de création d'un
tribunal spécial et c'est ce tribunal
qui doit établir chaque nom chaque
criminel depuis les idéologues de cette
agression en censée jusqu'à ceux qui ont
donné des ordres directs ceux qui ont
tué ceux qui ont violé ceux qui ont
mutilé personne ne doit échapper à sa
responsabilité car c'est cela la justice
merci le peuple français
à grande échelle contre le crâne et
avant tout pour l'aide militaire
décision de renforcer le crâne avec des
systèmes de défense anti-aérienne de
fournir les chars et les blindés sont
devenus des impulsions pour les autres
pays à adopter même décision la France a
toujours été et sera l'odeur grâce à
vous le lexique français s'enrichit de
nouveaux mots
aujourd'hui nous savons
ce que signifie crotale
et nous sommes prêts à continuer à
enrichir notre vocabulaire avec d'autres
mots
[Applaudissements]
parmi les Léopards les Abrahams les
challengers les clercs français qui nous
renforcerons au sol mais également les
mirages et les rafales qui ensemble avec
d'autres avions de nos alliés
protégeront le ciel ukrainien
donnez-nous les avions
les ailes de notre victoire
et ses ailes
[Applaudissements]
mais aussi l'ensemble de l'Europe chère
membre de l'Assemblée nationale la plus
grande valeur
que nous partageons c'est l'être humain
et je remercie le peuple
françaises qui ont accueilli les
Ukrainiens
[Musique]
des cent mille de mes concitoyens qui
ont trouvé refuge en France vous avez
donné aux enfants
ukrainiens
[Applaudissements]
la possibilité de poursuivre leurs
études leur scolarité vous avez assuré
aux Ukrainiens
une protection sociale vous avez créé
les possibilités pour qu'ils trouvent un
travail nous n'oublierons jamais
ou votre attitude à l'égard de nos
concitoyens pour les avez accueillis
comme les membres de votre propre
famille
de la famille française de la famille
européenne
revient à ses sources européennes
malgré la résistance féroce de Moscou
nous remercions de tout cœur la France
d'avoir
accordé à l'Ukraine le statut de
candidats à l'Union européenne le peuple
ukrainien paie aujourd'hui un prix
extraordinairement fort
notre peuple
connaîtra une
floraison au centre de la grande famille
européenne nous travaillons sur les lois
et l'introduction des réformes
nécessaires nous savons ce que nous
devons faire et comment le faire nous
avançons le plus vite possible même dans
les conditions de la guerre
je voudrais souligner que le président
de l'Ukraine le Parlement et le
gouvernement
font preuve de tolérance zéro à l'égard
de la corruption et se battent pour
éradiquer ce phénomène seulement en 10
derniers jours il y a eu des démissions
des fonctionnaires de haut niveau peut
scrupuleux qui seront condamnés qui
répondront de leurs actes car c'est cela
la démocratie
terminera le plus vite possible et
accomplira
toutes les mesures établies par la
Commission européenne j'espère que ça ne
permettra dès cette année d'ouvrir les
pourparler pour l'entrée à l'Union
européenne nous espérons également que
la France donnera le soutien politique
la demande ukrainien de son adhésion
accélérée dans le temps dans le contexte
du sommet de l'Alliance qui aura lieu à
Vénus le 11 12 juillet 23 car nous avons
prouvé par notre lutte que nous pouvons
nous devons devenir membre de la famille
européenne de l'Union européenne mais
aussi de l'Alliance atlantique chère
Assemblée nationale nous récurrons
souvent à l'histoire nos et cherchons
les explications de ce qui se passe et
de ce qui nous arrive aujourd'hui et je
voudrais évoquer ici dans ce noble
cercle un phénomène et un événement
historique qui s'appelle
[Musique]
qui a été évoqué par les citoyens
français Laurent Rucker suite aux
actions génocidaires du régime de
Staline en raison de cette famine
artificielle organisée en 32 33 des
millions du chrétien ont péri
et c'est aujourd'hui le signal venant de
France en reconnaissance la famille leur
demande en tant que je ne cite sera un
signal fort et important car comme par
le passé le régime soviétique
aujourd'hui et le régime de Poutine
n'aspire qu'à une chose détruire la
nation
ukrainienne
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de contribuer à la
reconnaissance législative de la famille
32 33 en tant que jeune acide du peuple
craignant
chers
commune j'en suis persuadée et après
cette victoire viendra la période de
reconstruction et de restauration nous
espérons aussi que la France votre
gouvernement vaut mieux d'affaires
pourront se joindre de manière active à
cette reconstruction de l'Ukraine de
l'après-guerre cette reconstruction doit
constituer l'histoire de succès de
l'ensemble du monde civilisé chers amis
aujourd'hui je m'adresse à vous au nom
de tous les Ukrainiens qui se battent
aujourd'hui qui donne leur vie pour leur
liberté leur dignité aujourd'hui je
parle au nom des citoyens ukrainiens qui
ce jour même aide l'armée continue à
travailler à étudier en croyant en leur
victoire et la vie Pacifique nous
voulons vivre dans une société pacifique
et civilisée que personne ne menace et
c'est pour cela que nous proposons les
formules de la paix au sommet de juin le
président de l'ainsky a proposé aux
leader mondiaux un plan de fin de la
guerre et notre formule de la paix
constituée de 10 points nous voyons que
la France est un leader puissant et qui
aidera à réaliser ce plan c'est
précisément grâce à l'aide de la France
et de nos autres partenaires et alliés
que nous voulons fixer les points clés
de la structure
post-guerre dans l'espace
euro-atlantique comprenant les garanties
pour l'Ukraine et nous comptons beaucoup
sur le soutien de cette formule de la
proposée par le président
ukrainien de la part de la France
à l'ukra tout le monde a parfaitement
entendu les paroles de président Macron
nous serons ensemble pour construire un
monde juste et solide comptez sur la
France comptez sur l'Europe nous avons
entendu ces paroles sous les tirs nous
les avons entendu sur le champ de
bataille et ses paroles ont retentit
plus fort que les explosions des obus et
les sirènes de l'alerte aérienne chers
amis en guise de conclusion
permettez-moi de cette haute tribune de
partager avec vous un rêve je me
souviens comment en 2012
de l'Euro 2012 il y a eu un match entre
les équipes nationales de France et
dukraine et cela a lieu à Donetsk au
stade Donbass Arena et ce match a été
interrupu par un orage
et moins de deux ans plus tard
l'agression russe l'occupation a
interrompu notre vie Pacifique la guerre
est entrée dans notre maison portant la
mort et la destruction
et je voudrais
gagner ensemble dans cette match contre
la mort et que nos équipes nationales
puissent de nouveau jouer dans Donetsk
libérée à Donbass Arena
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça sera le match de la paix et de la
mémoire
ce sera le match de la nouvelle vie je
vous remercie de votre attention gloire
à l'Ukraine et vive la France
[Applaudissements]